yeah welcome to this video yeah in this
video I'm presenting your game that I
recently saw and really left me stunned
because it's one of the most spectacular
games i've seen in in recent months or
years I don't know it was really amazed
then what's possible yeah this is a game
played just recently about two weeks ago
and the ECP my discord tournament I
think it was an MCM in the Netherlands
am yeah they tried something interesting
there they played according to the time
control rules of the 80s two and a half
hours for 40 moves so much more than
usual today and they also even had done
adjourned games for the younger audience
this means that they actually stop
playing after 40 moves and resume
playing only a day or so afterwards so
you can actually look at the game after
40 moves using the hub of friends on
nowadays your computer um yeah it was a
very interesting fighting tournament I'm
at the end one by vasily von Schaack
with a very fine performance um but the
game i'm going to show you is some
between an amused shook playing white
and email so toski playing black a few
words about the players yeah ladies
first them on a moody chokers some
currently the number two ranked female
player directly behind you de paga who
some got the top spot for like 20 years
now but music shotgun by now is some
place to even ahead of woman world
champion who you found so she's a very
promising female player rated 2606 so
above the 2600 barrier she's playing for
slovenia but is originally from the
Ukraine she's also got a very strong
playing younger sister I think um and
email so tov ski sm
one of the top players of Israel he's
rated to slightly below 2700 and his
known for his absolutely spectacular
style of playing he's really am one of
the sharpest players around he's some
not the kind of guy who plays for draw
at any stage so always interesting to
watch his games sometimes it's a bit
dumb yeah too much for his own good but
it makes for good good watching of
course so I'm let's see what happens in
this game so on on a moody took open sea
for insta-tox key plays the caro-kann
yeah nowadays them this is not
considered to be a the kind of rock
solid opening of the days of low cap or
for any other play in the 17th the
caro-kann is a good fighting weapon
mostly because white players what
players mostly go for the advanced
variation just in this just like in this
game because the main lines don't
promise wide so much so the old main
line so to say nowadays you can consider
the advanced variation the main line and
so we should have oops no it was too
quick Bishop f5 and here on white of
course has a huge of range of moves that
that can be played um the most common
move nowadays is some is them I need to
do this another way here is a shorts
variation with 93 but all kinds of other
move the possible also 93 Bishop e3 all
kinds of us and this game age for was
played which is also an interesting
alternative and now black has got them
mostly to to move seaplane h6 year which
is some may be the sharper move even the
alternative is this h5 just stopping
this G for IDM and its tracks after that
wider most often plays with the c forum
leading to quite a complex position this
line has been played numerous times by
am Peter Svidler for instance age for
line but citta ski played h6 and after
deform played Bishop Yvonne um we should
be forced again the sharper move like
also can play Bishop d7 just dropping
the piece back and this very often leads
to um yeah very original position some
normal kind of continuation would be
like this and it's quite funny white is
just plain pawn moves the eight first
eight moves doesn't have a piece
developed but this is some this is
playable why does got a nice space at
want to cheer on the on the King side of
course the lack of development is as
worrisome so it's not look like huge
advantage for white but it's some let's
play ball also in this position there's
the moves on night 2 D 2 in this
position which has been played in the
final inning game off the 19 no sorry
2004 World Championship match between
kramnik and Lego and so Kramnik played
this line when he needed to win
desperately but then okay let's return
to the game I'm so toski played their
Bishop before attacking of the rook so
why down and doesn't have much choice
please f3 and black jobs back so what is
the whole point of white set up and said
this move e six the idea is if black now
takes on e6 then after Bishop d3 this
some this whole kingside formation is
very problematic for black mostly
because he's got this awful bishop on f8
which young yeah probably will never see
a u-turn future in this game it can
happen that this piece will never move
because these pawns just block the
normal way of development and g6 is also
no movie
want to play so this is a huge advantage
for why it's almost not playable for
black this is why played queen to d6 so
threatening to take this with the Queen
so wyd needs to capture on f7 and here
we captured with a king yeah already in
a quite original position here the old
move future which has been played them
in the 70s and 80s when this position
came up it's not like a huge main line
why play it very often this kind of
stuff 92 but the intention of playing
Bishop f4 and then black played a five
something like like this here and black
I think has quite a quite a nice game he
needs to ya wee bit cautious with King
but white pieces are really far away
from posing any immediate threats and
like might even get something on the
e-file those white pawn moves are well
they gain space but they also weaken a
lot so black should be fine here this is
why I'm in this game f1 was played of
course this looks a bit weird white is
only making pawn moves and all in all
this game is a kind of don't try this at
home affair it's a spectacular to watch
but I guarantee you that if you try to
play yourself in this fashion at it will
get very tough ok what's playing fo and
of course the the simple idea is to just
block e5 what just wants to prevent if I
from being played and of course it is
got them other issues it weakens the
foursquare quite a lot so any kind of
peace Martin wait only for and of course
you are still not doing anything for
your development like develops a piece
Knight f6
and this is answered by another original
move Bishop h3 covering the g4 porn and
preparing g5 the issue was you cannot
really play g5 immediately of course
once in a while should develop stuff
with them g5 had the momentum has got
the problem you take here recapture then
this Bishop c2 and while the rookie is
hanging this is why white played Bishop
83 so Bishop age three and now black
yeah it's got more than one interesting
movie played c5 attacking the center
certainly a logical decision also
allowing for the night to come to c 6
with an active post on c67 would be
rather passive c6 really am so much
better square so what should why do now
there are a couple of alternatives I
mean a couple of smoke maybe too much
more like two or three moves she played
um the most aggressive move g5 directly
attacking the knight an alternative um I
can show briefly as the 93 which also
wasn't wasn't too bad 96 and now I'm a
funny line is g5 attacking the knight
takes takes here and now black has a
quite nice shot you can take on c2 not
much choice you need to recapture and
then rook takes h3 so some nice nice
tactics already happening a possible
continuation is rook takes 26 check 95
who takes takes
and take the rook he takes f he takes f
and mm well what what's this very very
difficult to assess position a possible
continuation i can i can show i mean
this is not completely forced with this
possible idea of course the Queen covers
but it can be an idea what also wants to
take control of the eight square so this
is why black plays this move with the
idea and this whole situation is
entirely entirely unclear could invest
lots of time to to analyze this blacks
got two pawns for the piece but you
gatech white still hasn't gotten service
or her pieces say I need to be cautious
in this comentary that I don't say his
pieces her pieces are still sleeping on
the queenside zone this line is some may
be problematic for white itself costs
difficult to play so this was some the
alternative in this position to play
Knight f3 but she played that the most
direct move g5 yeah like I'm captured on
g5 there for opening the age farm was
this is of course a very yeah a decision
you shouldn't take lightly it's a very
very tactical position but I think it's
better to do this instead of immediately
playing 94 after 94 immediately what has
got some additional options one sample
minus 93 96 and from the direct 95 check
the problem is after King to g8 White
has some the very direct move h5 with
the idea of pushing g6 and winning the
bishop it's quite amazing that white can
do all this with ya with a so queenside
oh ho ho oh cool haha Queen side are not
developed at all
but it is in fact player in fact label
this is some very dangerous position
then black sugar should capture and then
you've got the possible continuation of
taking takes here and then Queen g4 with
a very direct threat of Queen e6 checked
with the maid to come so black cannot
play any sort of move let's say it's
stupid yeah but just to show the made on
the board me very funny mate where
blacks king is box things almost
smothered mate so black needs to attend
to this and yeah most likely you need to
play g62 to get get some room for the
king and this is some also uh yeah not
not comfortable at all h6 is a good move
again intending the meteor and this
might continue along this lines are not
even this I think a stronger one I think
this is young I forgot that yeah
attacking the Queen and still you've got
this checks coming so why does the huge
attack i think this is almost winning
this is just a sample line to to
illustrate what might happen if black
doesn't take on on g5 in after g5 taking
here this is what you played i think
this is really better but must be super
difficult to play such a position they
also let me mention that i am this game
is not originally here from the server
so the the times displayed here are
complete bogus just ignore them I don't
know how much time they spent but I
can't imagine it was quite quite a lot
and at the end i guess it was Tom
trouble because you can easily spend
hours on this position so one takes
takes and now black
put the night in the center just erm
just a logical way to proceed yeah it
here and move which really shocked me um
I'm not sure if I would ever think about
this but it's apparently playable intent
quite okay here white played the amazing
move Bishop c8 yeah I really need some
time again to let the sink in so white
has only moved his her pawns and then
this this Bishop dropped from f1 to h3
to c8 with the intention of of grabbing
the Queen side and it's really amazing
that this is entirely okay I really
analyze this a bit on what the hell
bolts off of an engine and omit it
simply doesn't tell me that this is not
playable so um yeah quite an amazing way
to play so white threaten some to get
rid of there cuz so why don't threaten
Stu to take really here but also prepare
some further ideas on the king so moving
the Queen out to g4 h5 and also possibly
advancing further on the on the kingside
like f5 of course not at the moment
that's this check but them really
amazing that bishop CA TSM is a good
move yeah Black has got more than one
possible answer he played um I played
Knight to c6 just letting b7 yeah open
for taking and gaining a tempo on the
bishop a very natural moving on there
were alternatives another louth possible
would have been to capture on on deform
and then this might continue along these
lines not a queen to g4 with the idea of
now I'm really pushing
this move was also interesting at first
you think it's not playable at all
because of a queen before check but it's
not it's not that clear because there's
this funny possibility where suddenly
legs King is flushed into the open and
this is entirely unclear analyze it a
bit but hard to make sense of this it's
very difficult to understand a very
common result in those lines is is a
draw by repetition about my petrol check
because the Kings are so insecure but ok
on CD form I think the move that much
more likely to to occurs this Queen g
form because it's just the more
aggressive move with intentions to play
on the on the kingside a possible
continuation sg6 here and f5 it's really
a very straightforward play here f5 and
yeah what what could happen now I'm a
possibility is take take and King g7 now
g6 also with this idea I just could
continue like this think nice check and
yep black needs to move up here cannot
go back to this funny medium so needs to
need to it once with the king and all
this might easily end up you know yeah
in a very unclear end game night takes a
five
and then this might might be a
continuation something like this and
what this blacks got two pawns for for
peace but White's pieces are I just on
the back rank oh yeah some would lose so
maybe this is I don't know equal very
difficult so I'm at the end you can
conclude after Bishop to Bishop to see
eight let's return to the game Bishop to
c8 this capture was a possible
alternative but I think 96 is really
very very natural move because you want
to speed up your development here and
attack yourself and this is also very
yeah a typical of the task is it doesn't
worry so much about material he wants us
to take I'm going and hear ya why just
took on b7 it's amazing now black gum
played Queenie 6 which is something good
move intending to get to win material
here with the discover check and wide no
replied 92 I think this is probably the
most natural move and an alternative
here because you also need to develop at
one point but there was an interesting
alternative white could have played
Queen h5 check but this is the kind of
line you can yeah analyzed at home here
but to play this over the board is
really something else the main point is
black just plays Bishop g six and
sacrifice the rook on h eight and this
kind of position
it's really am yeah really am on over
the board how would you assess that
you're not not getting late adhere
blacks got a huge attack with two nights
Bishop Queen everything some
everything's pointing towards your king
and you've got nothing developed the
amazing thing is that here I looked at
this with an engine and white can
actually afford to take the rook so she
would have grabbed both rooks on the
initial squares and in this position
yeah black has yeah black and really
fire in all kinds of ways on white skin
but it seems so it's the king is it
seems able to to escape all this I can
show you one line which which is really
great night take CM if black wants to
draw by the way you can do so with
Nigeria the system rather
straightforward draw something like this
and this is also why white certainly
rejected this line because you you the
best you can do is to get a draw but
maybe your check mate it's impossible to
judge from the outset so very
understandable that she didn't go for
this but let's look at the line that's
one really great change not take see to
check King f1 you need to do this if you
if you play em kinky to their this wins
for black you just enter with the Queen
it's did this is very too much let's
let's say for instance this is quite
nice checkmate so you need to go to oops
to f1 and let me look at what what I
prepared here King f1 yeah Queen Isis
check 92 and 23
and this intense queen here or here with
me to come so it already looks rather
desperate so what should why do um what
can play 92 which barely holds but what
can also try this ruthless desperado sec
to get the Queen out of this dominant
position on d3 and this funny enough
answer with a very neat line takes takes
Queen takes f5 takes just six check so
it's a it's a total mess and in this
position um you should buy five has
played because you cannot take on a one
because just check and you lose have a
dent yeah I think also very close to
getting mated so it's it's a total mess
Bishop f5 and black has got two
exchanges sacrifice but the huge tank on
the king so at gate could could end in
with any possible result here but the
main point was after after this let me
return a couple of moves that besides
this this night check oops this one was
also draw so this is why wider didn't go
for this I think it's just a bedtime a
bad deal so you know you the best you
can get is a draw but you can easily
lose so it's a it's no good so at the
end why developed a piece 92 and here
would be 8 / black attacking the bishop
which captured on c6 very
very logical play Queen takes c6 and
here I'm just sorry I forgot one line
which was really really neat in this
position I wear black played rugby aid
it was also possible to take on deform
this is a quite quite funny line I
forgot about this this is quite a funny
line if white would now capture on eight
this one would follow an idea three
check King f1 and then the great move
Bishop f5 and yeah this is now winning
for black because of check this neat
little thing checkmate very nice mate
with the the Knights and the Queen
mating white skin so after night takes
d4 here oops after night XD for what
what couldn't take here so you might I
don't have much choice I think you you
need to to capture here takes and then
possibly Queenie to yeah it's it's
really a messy position black color
plate is I think black is perfectly ok
here um it could could continue for
example root ph and then white might
rejoice g6 move it's quite funny if you
take what the the Queen now we've got
should be five but this is in fact the
easiest way to proceed to e6 takes on
before the media check on reform
and all this at the end funny enough you
might might have guessed it ends in a
draw but it's a quarter quite a funny
funny line who takes him rook takes on
h8 it takes the check and at the end
black will they'll get the piece back
and it's it's a draw with opposite color
bishops of course a very deep line and
impossible to calculate but 94 was an
alternative this um this move here was
an alternative so let's return to turn
to the game in fact I already suspect
that this will be a very long video
because there are so many possibilities
rupee eight it takes and now i'm wide
continued in the most aggressive fashion
she really through everything that likea
f5 with the idea of yeah just pushing
further g6 or possibly taking on g6 and
then take on age 7 and then g7 a g6 so
yeah white really a text with all our
forces that she's got in play at the
moment black now I'm answered with the
g6 very very understandable move
stopping stopping the pawn there
actually were alternatives I want to
show one really funny line let's say
Queen g8 a king a king g8 also also
possible and now a very neat Linus says
Bishop f4 attacking the rook rook takes
b2 and Quincy one attacking the rook and
still intending this g6 push
let's say black hair covers this and
then g6 first you think I am this might
be winning for white because uh yeah
it's now it's now I'm winning material
but in fact I can take here takes so
okay black luster lost the peace but of
course them he's got them quite some
attack going and the neat thing is if
white now place night them 92 you've got
d3 coming the point being if white takes
we have to check kinky one and now at
first you think okay it's all over black
doesn't have a queen check anyway
anywhere and the rook is saying and
everything's hanging but then you might
spotted this absolutely beautiful move
Queen f1 check only move and just check
and the draw by virtual check one of the
craziest Perpetual's I've ever seen a
very Queen f 19 f to check and sometimes
amazing what what you can find so yeah
just a neat line it's a not not forced
or something but really cool so but
black played g6 also understandable and
of course why term is far beyond any
normal or let's say developing moves you
just need to throw everything I'd like
so not a form with the idea of taking on
87 and grabbing on g6 yeah and the next
move is really a also also quite amazing
he just played Bishop g7 and yeah why it
doesn't have
have much choice she she really needs to
do this now and he has slow move from
just leaves black with much the better
development and and just an attack note
that white is still playing without the
queenside and okay she took on age 7 and
some as it was intended like we captured
takes on g6 and first year I think what
the hell is black doing because you
think okay you need to move the King
takes let's say check again and then
queen 85 and isn't white just a piece of
with an attack also to come night queen
age 7 and so on yeah that's all true but
the point is if you like and just take
with the Queen quite an amazing idea if
why it would take now like a get this
check in and wins back the Queen again
at the end at first you might think okay
let's let's look at this whites a pawn
up but in fact this is some close to
losing already because black will get to
the g5 porn in any case and you will
also get d 4 because at first you might
think okay maybe you can take on c5 the
black has the very forceful move rook
takes me tube and this in fact them yeah
when's instantly like just threatens to
move the Rope back now and then the
undeveloped queenside really are yeah
leads to leads to White's defeat yeah
you cannot take the Queen really so it's
a queen sacrifice which cannot be
accepted and there's also not much
alternatives now because there's simply
this enormous threat so white needs to
play
f3 you need to cover h1 not not nothin
else yeah and now again you think okay
what's the what now if black moves the
Queen they're still g6 so what should
black play and he came up with again an
amazing move rook f8 and by now I was
really really stunned by this game
because the great point is if white
would capture now on g6 black can simply
recapture and let's say the queen is
attacked by by the rook let's say the
Queen was black just takes on deform and
Lexus black ass a whole Queen down a
queen for a rock down and the problem is
his attack is so strong because of
whites undeveloped pieces it's really
like a game from from the 19th century
Black has got such a huge attack with
rook f2 to come that is just winning in
this position it's it's not much what
what can do for example you can you can
try something like this not developing
something but you always get this muth
and what doesn't have have anything that
she can do let's say a queen here please
dude it's the medial mate so it's it's
just too much you cannot again grab the
Queen amazing so in fact I think there's
only one playable move in this position
and this is watching what she played 92
attacking attacking the knight and in a
way trying to develop some pieces like
has sacrificed a piece already so you
need to really catch up and try to
cannot get meted um right now took on g5
this is
again the best move you can look at all
kinds of alternatives but then this
video would be like three hours long why
took now and here like we tried to win
he could have also played and he played
a queen g1 check okay he also could have
played I'm taking on e4 but this would
allow queen bee three check and this is
an immediate draw by perpetual check the
King cannot go here because of some
[ __ ] need made so it needs to go back
and then this will be a perpetual check
black cannot escape with his King this
was rather easy taking only form leading
to a draw but black I wanted to try
harder if you played this check okay
white doesn't have much choice and she
needs to move the king and now he gave
this check this was I think the the
toughest alternative night drop back
that the issue is all the way if you
would take oops if you would take than
this there's always this draw with queen
bee three so this is why this check is
almost forced nine f2 and King g8 was
played now here like also could have
tried to play King e8 trying to get out
of those checks with 25 but in fact
White has a nice resource here and maybe
King yet was the way to go to try to try
to win this game here white needed to
put beautiful needed to find Bishop e3 I
think she would have she would have
found it because um it's really the
first move you think of because you need
to get to black skin to secure a
perpetual so you need to move to
sacrifice the rupiah Queen takes 25 and
now black doesn't have a chat
there are meaningful meaningful check
and there are still those check threats
um and black cannot escape the perpetual
again you can look look at this a bit
for yourself it's no way to escape it
always some always checks on the light
squares so maybe this was a bit tougher
to let let white find you should be
three but then he played clue g8 and now
white gladly i think captured d5 ruka
728 and now black gum doesn't have any
alternative really at some it's
impossible to escape the perpetual
unless you play which is what you didn't
do if he could have played Bishop f8
this was a possibility to escape the
immediate perpetual but this can also
easily lead to a loss because it's such
a messy position a possible continuation
would be Queen f3 then for instance e6
Bishop e3 queen takes a one-win check
here takes takes takes d4 and night
before with this idea and it's a total
mess I looked at it a bit deeper with
the computer and it almost always ended
in some sort of Perpetual check so I
think this is maybe a similar situation
to be four black saw that after this of
course Rookie of eight is a perpetual
and it's a draw and Bishop FA dis maybe
yeah asking a bit of a bit too much from
the position you you're still in
constant danger of getting into
perpetual and it's um well the
risk-reward ratio is just
just not right so on at the end he
played them rook to f8 Queen d5 check
and just a couple of those checks out in
fact after this check a draw was agreed
in this absolutely amazing game yeah my
advice is some I really am and it's now
a 40-minute something video and if you
if you got some time on your hands just
have a look at this game i'll also post
the the game score in the description
have a look at this for yourself if you
want you can use an engine on computer
to help you but if you've got some time
on your hands just trying to analyze a
bit the lines because it's a nice
training for for tactics it's a such a
hugely complicated game and very very
much fun to analyze um yeah maybe it's
some alternative to watching the
Olympics of your being tired of this my
advice is oh yeah look at some nice
chess games like this one you hope you
enjoyed it I'll be back soon with new
videos till then bye